president biden's almost two trillion
dollar spending package jumped its first
hurdle friday morning the bill was
passed by the house in a party-line vote
with one democrat voting against it the
social safety net and climate bill now
goes to the senate where democratic
leaders must wrangle all 50 members to
get that bill passed without major
changes christina raffini is at the
white house christina good morning to
you
good morning jeff well democrats did
what they said they wanted to do and
that's get this bill through the house
before thanksgiving now the question
remains can they get it through the
senate and onto the president's desk
before the next holiday break
hours after the 1.75 trillion dollar
build back better bill finally cleared
the house the buildback better bill is
passed a cheerful president biden
pardoned a turkey i pardon you turkey is
infrastructure
peanut butter and jell are going to help
build back the butterball as we move
along the social spending bill is
stuffed with democratic priorities like
expanded medicare prescription drug
reform universal pre-kindergarten and
hundreds of billions to fight climate
change this bill is monumental
it's historic
it's transformative it's bigger than
anything we've ever done but the
legislation almost risked becoming a
turkey itself after months of delay in
democratic infighting and a last-minute
roast from minority leader kevin
mccarthy
today
i got my booster shot more people in
america thought elvis was alive and the
stimulus created a job did you take a
bathroom break and i didn't who stalled
the vote with a record-breaking eight
and a half hour floor speech
never in american history will so many
taxes be raised and so much borrowing be
to be needed to pay for all this
reckless spending now the bill heads to
the senate where changes are almost
guaranteed we've been working with the
senate and the white house been working
with the senate throughout this process
so we're very hopeful that it doesn't
change that much with a razor thin
majority and no republican support
democrats will need all 50 senators on
board meaning hard-fought measures like
paid family leave and immigration reform
could be on the chopping block it's
going to take a while to get through the
senate i think it'll probably be after
thanksgiving
i will sign it period
now in addition to pardoning turkeys and
celebrating legislative momentum the
president also went to the doctor
yesterday in a nearly five-hour visit at
walter reed medical center he received
routine health screenings that concluded
among other things he's clearing his
throat more during speaking engagements
likely due to acid reflux and he's
walking a little stiffer from
osteoarthritic wear and tear on his
spine but the overall conclusion is that
the president is healthy and turns 79
years old today michelle
wow happy birthday to the president
christina thank you so much